[Musique]
chose d'épisodes [ __ ] j'ai adoré ce
soir mais pour les aspirateurs away
connexion quoi c'est tellement black
mirror quand enfin de quoi mais c'est
tellement black mirror enfin c'est comme
ça c'est pas une coïncidence ou ça je
crois je capte pas ta définition de
black mirror il faut que tu me genre par
exemple ça c'est quoi par exemple c'est
blake meilleur ça mais c'est un
téléphone l'ordi là sur lequel on vient
de regarder l'épisode de black mirror
c'est blake mais rossi genre ça ça c'est
une blague bien sûr ça a tant fait avoir
vas-y blackmar en vrai
[Musique]
à
il doit vraiment augmenté baptisé vous
inquiétez pas je juge pas mais aussi je
voulais j'hésite à utiliser cette
application une application quoi il est
question
ben vous avez utilisé l'application qui
permet de cloner les êtres chers décédé
mais ouais c'est ça en fait tout ce qui
est un peu électronique futuriste pour
toi c'est black mirror mais par exemple
ça
ce truc il monde c'est black mirror ça
je comprends pas oui docteur noba
écoutez c'est assez urgent là elle sort
tout juste de la réalité virtuelle mais
j'ai l'impression qu'elle s'y croit
encore
mais d'après ce que j'entends elle est
enfermée dans un dans un corps d'une
jeune femme de 23 ans les 6 au 9 juin
sainte beuve et ses clones et nous
avions fait nantes de tout se passait
mais par contre c'est très bien avec la
tête à tête mais c'est cool a en tout
cas c'est super
pourquoi je le fais parce que quand je
le vois là comme ça je vous dis
ça avec les black mirror black mirror je
vous présente le clou du spectacle
figurez vous que dans ce petit tronçon a
été enfermé la conscience d'une
personnes assoiffées de sang et de
combats
comment ça je vais vous montrer
moi c'est booba ben quoi prenez pas
votre café 1
je gardais en attendant
si je te dis est-ce que tu m'entends
c'est pour cela qu'avant 18 heures sur
tous les sites de télévision en direct
le premier ministre messieurs
il va falloir trouver une solution très
rapidement mes équipes tentent de
localiser l'endroit de la transmission
et en quelques heures
ça va être compliqué nous vous prenez
part à des jeux ledez le cochon mois on
a tous les rappeurs disponible en
peluche
alors vous avez il ya plus j'adore le
pardon j'ai dit je le baise nos cochons
monsieur on va tout d'abord continuer à
chercher une solution alternative
j'ai dit ça pourrait aider mes amis
vivant je vous comprend deux salles où
votre volonté de soutien monsieur le
premier ministre vous êtes formidables
en vous tient au courant
si les mois je vous en prie madame le
concert est par hasard vous avez une
photo du cochon
[Musique]
ouh là bonjour je suis olivier de
carglass
[Musique]
je croyais que tout était vrai mais
depuis le début tout était dans mes
lunettes de réalité virtuelle
quel twist tout le sketch depuis la
première vannes moi je m'y attendais pas
je sais pas vous mais ouf comme tous
mais quand même c'est pas moi je trouve
ça bouffe
chacun sait ce dont on trouve ce qu'on
veut de ouf ou pas c'est pas assez
subjectif à riga bonne fin de vidéo